the dark side siamo nella
trendy mi sembrano allora diciamo che
tramite una serie di lavori che andremo
a vedere cercheremo di definire se c'è
un lato oscuro in basilicata legato
all'arte contemporanea o i suoi aspetti
legati al lato oscuro dell'essere umano
proprio no io sono per la scienza quindi
di base penso che un'opera d'arte debba
portare la società a migliorarla quindi
creare una criticità trame l'altro c'è
l'opera non deve semplicemente essere
qualcosa che si appende al muro quindi a
pagare l'artista ma ci vuole un dialogo
tra me e le persone
quindi diciamo che l'immortalità
dell'opera d'arte e cioè se e come un po
l'immortalità dell'anima cioè si tende a
vivere il dopo e non l'ora e qui adesso
invece sono per esprimere dei concetti
che possono cambiare la società ora come
si traduce un pensiero del genere magari
così concettuale in un'opera tipo questa
no questa si intitola my room sarebbe la
mia stanza dove produceva le mie opere a
milano come potete vedere è una finestra
a finestra un po un simbolo stereotipato
del quello che è il futuro
voi vedete dalla finestra quello che ci
sarà dopo il futuro la speranza eccetera
io ho spostato le tende ne è uscita
fuori una bara chiaramente per qualcuno
l'avrà vista allora cosa voglio dire che
il buio il dark sa dice noi veniamo dal
buio perché i nostri organi si sono
formati nel buio di uno stomaco del dg
della pancia di nostra della nostra
mamma e poi c'è stato la vita e poi di
nuovo ci sarà il buio che molto
probabilmente corrisponderà alla bara la
terra eccetera quindi buio luce buio in
quel lasso di tempo di vita che noi
abbiamo possiamo decidere se spenderla
con mediocrità o in maniera diciamo
eccellente poi in base anche a livello
culturale e religioso di una persona
la persona decide se dopo ci sara luce
eterna o tenebre
questi lavori all'apparenza sembrano
cinici o sembrano magari macabri ma in
realtà io speculo passatemi il termine
sul lato oscuro per parlare di vita come
direbbe rick from io sono un bio filo
c'è cerco di portare la luce lì dove non
c'è come in questo caso questo è un
opera molto cruda tant'è vero che si
intitola roma
crudo ed è un prosciutto diciamo che per
la gastronomia sarebbe una eccellenza
del per il palato no se la guardiamo da
un altro punto di vista è una gamba di
un animale morto
quindi che cosa ho fatto io ho
ritagliato uno spazio dove poter
installare una protesi di denti vera che
l'ha installato un dentista
io sono andato dal dentista col
prosciutto in braccio fatto la fila come
è quindi ho curato anche le carie quindi
cosa cerco di fare cerco di portare in
vita le cose morte quindi un po come
mary shelley con frankenstein questo
voglio dire quest'opera qui magari è
molto sensazionalista quindi fa molto
breccia sui blog sui siti esposta
l'istituto italiano di cultura a los
angeles a new york ho fatto il giro del
mondo ma voglio dire che è un idea non
si può controllare cioè un'idea non si
può controllare diciamo il successo di
un'opera d'arte e neanche le influenze
che avrà nel tempo e nella società anche
per un altro motivo perché siamo in un
periodo storico in cui tutto è arte 15
st voce c'è un élite di persone che ne
ha sdoganato questo atteggiamento e
questo ne decreta la morte di una
miriade di artisti che sono
impossibilitati nell'esporre i luoghi
pubblici o privati che penso
semplicemente che un artista dovrebbe
fare quello che gli piace di più e
confrontarsi con con la società mi
interessano le streghe in qualche modo
qui ritorna un po la basilicata perché
la basilicata le streghe sono sono
diciamo qualcosa che appartiene alla
cultura mitico religiosa di ogni di ogni
luogo e da tutta l'italia ma anche tutta
l'europa
qui io ho preso ad esempio allora non si
vede grimilde che sarebbe la strega di
biancaneve che ossessionata dalla sua
immagine quindi un personaggio che si
consuma nella sua vanità e questo anche
un'altra critica alla nostra società che
è calata un po in questo delirio
narcisistico fatto di vanità vacuità di
sel fi
del piacersi a tutti i costi
allora cosa succede questa scultura è
fatta di rossetto quindi questo è l'idea
perché di rossetto perché il simbolo
diciamo della cosmetica quindi l'artista
cosa fa di base per quanto ci sia la
tecnologia cerca di replicare un po
quello che fa a dio cioè dio crea quindi
plasma l'uomo con il fango
l'artista cosa fa cerca di plasmare
l'essere contemporaneo con la cosmetica
questo cosa voglio dire che che che di
base cioè il corpo la bellezza tende a
svanire come il corpo umano
la bellezza rimane solo nella memoria
delle persone quindi le streghe diciamo
è un tema che mi serve a parlare di
altro come in questo caso non si vede
abbastanza bene è un video che ho fatto
su gesualdo da venosa che un musicista
del cinquecento e quindi lo ho fatto in
modo che lui fosse un uomo in ginocchio
e avesse attorno a sé questi cinque
strategie che lo attanagliano è chiuso
dentro una stella perché la stella è uno
dei simboli esoterici che tendono ad
allontanare le streghe il malocchio
eccetera eccetera
in basilicata le streghe si chiamano le
magiare sarebbero questi spettri ce ne
sono sette per ogni paese e il 7 un
numero che torna spesso perché i 7
non lo so perché 7 e anche il numero
delle volte in cui la strega deve
contare questa scopo di saggina che si
mette dietro la porta per scacciare
sempre le stringhe insomma oppure altri
metodi per tirare il malocchio e questo
sacchetto si vede un po che tipo un
sacchetto di stoffa un sacchetto di
stoffa con dentro vari intrugli tipo le
zampe di talpa i santini religiosi e
scusate da leader e quindi diciamo che
un immaginario che potrebbe piacere
molto ai o da ros che diceva no allora
cosa succede questi sono tutta una serie
di input che ti vengono d'attis e tu
nasci in un luogo così ma anche negli in
altri voglio dire
tu li cerchi di tradurli altri ii.vv
personalmente come in questo caso questo
è un disegnino che io faccio sulle
moleskine disegno tutto su carta e poi
traduca in opera in base all'idea vedete
c'è un bambino seduto a terra
no di spalle che sta guardando la coda
di una lucertola spezzata quando si
spezza la coda di una lucertola continua
a muoversi no si muove
e l'unico modo per tenere a bada questa
maledizione io guardavo questo bambino e
questo bambino continuava a ripetere non
sono stato io è stato la vecchia non
sono stato io è stata la recchia di un
po paura diciamo che nascendo abbastanza
inquietante per quello magari faccio le
opere dark quindi che cosa vuol dire che
la nonna le aveva esattamente spiegato
che dicendo ripetutamente questa frase
si potevano scacciare i diavoli il
malocchio tenere a bada questa questa
maledizione
però se ci pensate anche a livello
psicanalitico è facilissimo pensare che
questa è una coazione a ripetere cioè lo
diceva anche freud
quando un bambino ripete le cose
ossessivamente cerca di ripetere le
tante volte ho cerca di fare l'azione
tantissime volte lo fa solo per un
semplice motivo per allontanare il senso
di colpa che ha provato magari spezzando
questa questa coda di lucertola quindi
questa sarà la mia prossima
installazione che non vi dirò però
questa è un'altra idea che ho ritrovato
tempo fa quando maria pia mi ha invitato
per parlare the dark side riaperto nei
moli skin ho trovato questo lavoro di
sette anni fa disegnato così un po po
scrauso però c'è un concetto dietro che
questo si diceva
me lo diceva una tipa che quando i
contadini andavano ad arare la terra oa
pure a
insomma coltivare i campi di grano
portavano con sé i propri figli bambini
che ovviamente non avevano una baby
sitter no e quindi devono tenere lì a
vista d'occhio perché qual era la paura
più grande è la più la paura più grande
era che i serpenti di nuovo tornano si
serpenti i serpenti entrassero nella
culla del bambino
no non per mangiarsi il bambino ma per
entrare nello stomaco del bambino per
poi fuoriuscire e succhiare il latte
materno
quindi chi dice che si chiami il latte
avvelenato
allora che cosa fa un artista
contemporaneo cosa centra un artista con
una roba del genere c'entra che deve
cercare il modo di trasformarla in
un'opera d'arte per farla arrivare in
tutti i musei del mondo le gallerie
eccetera
io l'ho trasformata così quindi questa è
lì è la mia idea di arte si vede è un
serpente che si annida tra i pulcini
quindi si annida tra i più piccoli è
mimetizzato no quindi un serpente
mimetizzato tra i più deboli perché un
po una metafora della società
contemporanea cioè che tutti tendono c'è
sempre il più furbo che tende a farvi le
scarpe a casa in famiglia sul posto di
lavoro che ne so quindi questa è una
metafora ma cosa voglio dire che le idee
cioè io non mi so inventato nulla di
base perché in arte cioè nulla si crea
nulla si distrugge tutto si trasforma in
arte invece tutto si ridisegna i temi
sono quelli di sempre
ciò che rende contemporanea un opera e
il suo linguaggio e come per il
vocabolario certe parole parole sono
uscite altre sono entrate come lo slang
oppure le persone che mi ha raccontato
delle storie no le nonne che mi
raccontavano delle storie ore sarebbero
definite tipo del storyteller no oppure
se avessero influenzato il pubblico
usando una parola che è tipica del mondo
del marketing della moda sarebbero stati
degli influencer per capirci
quindi questo diciamo un po secondo me
l'arte contemporanea alla traduzione poi
cosa faccio vado a cercare da dalle
figure del carnevale
il carnevale di alcune regioni quindi
stiamo parlando di basilicata hanno
delle cose particolarmente dark a mio
avviso quindi vedete le pupazze che sono
queste sette streghe appese a
montescaglioso oppure tanti i diavoli ci
sono sempre i diavoli in qualche modo se
cristo si è fermato ad eboli vuol dire
che dietro ci sono i diavoli non lo so
comunque pieno di diavoli ma questo
immaginario che può affascinare tutto un
mondo legata da una cinematografia serve
sempre a parlar di luce e io scelgo una
figura del carnevale che è molto
affascinante che questa qui si chiama
air unità e romita significa l'eremita
l'eremita sarebbe sarebbero queste
persone che durante il carnevale si
vestono da d'albero e vagano per il
paese portando diciamo un messaggio
verde ecologico come potete vedere fatto
da una serie di volontari che vestono
ogni anno queste persone fatte di di
edera e come lo traduce un artista io in
questo caso ne ho realizzato un
monumento vero che esiste tuttora provar
satriano dove c'è quest'albero che
sfonda il pavimento quindi una scultura
di tre metri mostro grande e c'è un uomo
su che è a metà tra essere umano e
pianta quindi non essere fitomorfi co
definiamolo così che cosa rappresenta
rappresenta il vero legame tra l'essere
umano e l'ambiente
quindi il vero legame questo in un epoca
storica diciamo dove le tematiche
collegate alla disumanizzazione
dell'essere umano perché c'è questa
tecnologia invasiva che diciamo
addirittura più oltrepassare sfumano noi
non siamo pronti per questa tecnologia
io parlo di questo magari sarà un
discorso vintage ma quali sono i
discorsi non lo so per me mi interessa
questo mi interessa che ci sia un
messaggio importante legato al rapporto
tra essere umano e ambiente quindi
questo è un modo per tradurre lo potete
vedere sembra un guerriero male un
guerriero dentro no quindi con questo
ragionamento ora concludo dicendo questo
è stato cosa fa un po ridere e
divertente
praticamente prima abbiamo parlato di
serpenti di diavoli di tutto questo
immaginario da cui tirar fuori luce non
si vedeva tirar fuori luce e se ci
pensate che a matera sono stati girati
tutta una serie di film legati alla
figura di gesù cristo e mai della sua
controparte che sarebbe il diavolo tra
virgolette ma realtà ci sono tutti
questi film ci sta il film di pasolini
ci sta il film di mel gibson bla bla bla
soliti discorsi invece molto
probabilmente non si parla mai tipo del
demonio dove ci sono queste donne
impossessate dal diavolo
no perché impossessate dal diavolo
perché così facile tracciare una donna
di essere strega nel momento in cui esce
fuori dal suo recinto di regole chiaro
oppure c'è non si sevizia un paperino
del grandissimo lucio fulci dico io sono
un grande fan è ambientato ad accettura
invece è rappresentato come accentua
quindi il diavolo per certi versi è
presente no ma il diavolo di base chi è
il diavolo per per dante alla fine loro
definisce ditte di te chi è colui che
separa lui colui che divide e questo
posto la basilicata è un microcosmo che
riproduce un macrocosmo cioè si parla di
qua ma si parla di italia si parla di
europa europa i popoli sono divisi le
culture sono divise e io ve lo
rappresenta in una maniera più facile
possibile prendendo un frame del film o
mense se sei il presagio girato a matera
girato a matera ovviamente non è
rappresentata matera a israele e c'è ad
hollywood questa scena in cui cercano il
diavolo cercano dove il diavolo dove il
diavolo ma qualcuno gli è sfuggito
questo frame
non lo so se si vede c'è la scritta aids
cioè potenza idsc vuol dire vuol dire
che è un dettaglio il diavolo sta nei
dettagli
questo è il vero lato oscuro
un film sul diavolo dove a trovare
potenza e di s
io quando l'ho vista al cinema sono
saltato dalla sedia ci potevo credere
volevo dire semplicemente che il vero
lato oscuro sono queste faide tra
potenza matera di altre città
l'italia l'europa eccetera bisogna
[Applauso]
quindi è paradossale che ci sia in
questo film concludo dicendo che ogni
persona può utilizzare il proprio lato
oscuro perché non esiste lato oscuro
senza luce e decidere da che parte stare
quindi lucania vuol dire terra di luce e
lucifora è colui che porta alla luce
grazie
[Applauso]